oh and his family partially owned the
place it was a business next door they
sold wine
like garyvee or whatever a guy's name is
Jerry V telling people to [__] sell
their home and sleep in their yard you
know what I'm saying and that dude was
raised on a damn wine wine farm or
something dude he's into that [__]
you know what I'm saying dude hiding
grapes in his ass at night freezing
grapes and [__] hiding him in his ass
and he's telling people how to struggle
dude that got out of his mind he's like
oh damn dude oh you still have
silverware in your house [__] sell it
and he shows up and he'll like hug the
dude the guy can't even he has no way to
get food in his mouth you know the guy's
[__] just knuckling through some
chowder knuckling through some Booyah
base and he's like no worries 76 last
night and he hugs him you know what I'm
saying it's like what the [__]
and then he drives off and the family's
just standing there and apart
another winner
out of his [__]
dude
and he hugs oh he sold two extra
Christmas sweaters you didn't need from
last year and they're crying together
like what is going on
um but anyway I don't and look man I
gotta give some love to my boy I'm sorry
the videos I'm not saying the guy's not
a smart guy the videos though and the
guy it grew up well off well no I think
he actually didn't grow up well off
that's part of his that could be lion no
you partially lying but it's not really
lying if you don't know but he was he
grew up you know his dad owned like a
corner liquor store or something and he
did you know he got after it created the
uh but in my neighborhood a corner
liquor store and then she was a winery
so if you're looking at it from baby
from Theo Vaughn's perspective hell yeah
he grew up like big time oh yeah look at
these dudes over here huh
slang in that Reese laying there